And I'm 100% confident. I did
nothing wrong. Right. From a huge,
as a human being or a comic,
you know,
like maybe reading the room would have
been a thing I did, but I was like,
I was like, I know these people. These
are my fucking brethren. Like I, yeah,
I got fucking took calculus with you
people. You're like, yeah, I know.
I know the kind of Shit that me and my
Asian friends and my Indian friends would
talk when we were in fucking school like
this. This is fucking light work. Right.
Right. And so, so maybe that, but
even then I'm like, no, fuck that.
I'm not going to fucking think about
that going awry. You know what I mean?
But yeah, it was, it was
crazy. Yeah. Well it's,
it's an educational experience and
net positive overall without a doubt.
And it also gives us an opportunity
to make fun of these kids,
which I think they need.
They need to realize that the world
thinks they're fools. Yeah. And I,
and I really believe that all,
I've read several articles on your case,
your situation rather your case
caught a case. I got comedy me today.
You know,
all the articles that I've read
were all essentially positive.
Yeah. And they were all, you know,
mocking these fucking little children.
I want to say for the record
that I was on the record,
I still think that it was at
the still think that though.
It's like the minority of that group,
especially at Columbia for sure. Sure.
You know,
like it's just that they happen to like,
cause the majority of those kids were
like amped and like had a good time.
And even if that can happen though word,
some majority a majority can like you
in a minority can stand up and then the
majority doesn't do anything
about it. You just go, wow,
that shit hurt my feelings.
No, no, no. Those kids,
those kids saying like let them stay, let
them stay. But it wasn't like a chorus,
which is what I would
have hoped. But um, yeah,
they're a little fucking babies and they
need to hear it. They need to hit it.
The little babies, cause that's
how you grow up. You know, you,
you'd do something ridiculous and then
people criticize you and then you realize,
oh, I'm kind of ridiculous.
Yeah, let me just check myself.
Then it hurts your feelings and
you fight it off for a little bit.
You try to pretend you battle it,
but overall over the course of time you're
going to absorb that information and
hopefully those kids are going
to grow and mature. Yeah.
I mean I have friends that were
like completely progressive, Weirdo,
crazy off the charts like activists
10 years ago and now they're like way,
way mellow and they've just like,
what was wrong with me?
I was virtue signaling I was trying too
hard and they realize like the lot of
what they were doing was just
wasting energy and it was just,
it just a lot of adjuncts
in a lot of just trying to,
trying to affect change in order to
make themselves feel better. Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Trying to push buttons in order
to validate their existence.
That's what a lot of that,
that that specific instant felt like
it was like it was either like a, nope,
we have an opportunity to
assert our sort of rightness,
however wrong it is here and be like,
this is,
we're going to take a stand and
yeah, this is who we are. I'm like,
y'all just just chill. Yo, chill
the fuck out. What the fuck?
Yeah. It's, there's a lot of foolishness,
but this is the world we live in and
I think there's a big part of that
accentuated by the fact that we have
a maniac for president. Yo. Yeah.
That's what it is.
Because they feel like that eval needs
to be combated at every turn because we
didn't before and we let this guy
get into office and now here he is,
and the Mueller probe and
all this fucking craziness.
When Obama was president, it
shit felt a lot cooler. Yeah.
I mean now it's like Trump is present.
Everyone was like, Oh shit man,
bunker down.
What'd you know?
We realize all you have to do is be
popular and you can be president.
Like that's insane. Yeah. I used
to be, you had to be qualified.
We used to think that you understood
national policy, foreign policy,
you understood defense. You understood
exactly what's going on with the economy.
Basic English. Yeah. Yeah.
That guy doesn't know shit.
He's just trying to make money. And
wouldn't you love to be a fly on the wall?
I would.
Cause what we're getting,
all the crazy is him when he knows
cameras are on them. Oh yeah.
I would love to see what he's like alone.
Like what is,
I would love to see him
like watch Fox News.
I like to like sit in our cheeseburger.
Just fucking cry. He's a crazy person.
It's really weird, man. It's
unnerving. And that's what I think.
Like what a lot of what we're seeing on,
especially with this particular thing
is the thing where it's like you don't
have control in any other
facet of your life necessarily.
So you're going to try to exert it
in a way that you think is positive,
when in fact you're doing the
opposite of what you, you're,
you're liberal sensibilities are.
Yeah.
I think it's also a trend and I think,
um,
that political correctness and
it comes in waves and it existed.
It was pretty, pretty
strong in the 80s, you know,
like political correctness was a washing
over people in the 80s and destroy rap
and shit and it's coming
back and it'll go away again.
People get sick of it and it'd be
ridiculous and people will rebel against
political correctness center it.
But I think overall the
culture is trying to adjust.
It's trying to self adjust. We're
trying to, the, the actual culture,
the as a whole is trying to eliminate
racism and eliminate sexism and eliminate
bias, which are good noble
goals there. Good number goals,
right? But along the way,
as you have these polar extremes
of people that are doing it wrong,
poor execution, terrible execution
and everyone understanding,
and it's also strange to me,
it's like what utopia are you
trying to create by silencing stuff?
Because just because you do
that, just because you say, oh,
you can't say racist shit
doesn't mean it goes away.
Or you can't say sexy
shit doesn't mean it's a,
that's more like you're treating the
symptom and not the disease. Right.
But in their defense does talking
about very specific platform, right.
This is a stage.
If you had actually said
something actually racist
then it would make sense that
hey, we don't want anybody telling
racist you 100% right. Yeah.
So they but they wanted it to be
racist. Yeah. That's the thing.
It's like Yo just fucking take a minute,
take a second to relax and once I get it,
is that what utopia have you
read about that's ever been real?
Like every book we read in high
school, College, brave new world,
Lord of the flies [inaudible] or animal
farm like the giver we read in fucking
Middle School,
that's all a utopia.
But this fuck fucking killing
babies and you know south all of it.
It's all a fucking false utopia
kind of situation. There's,
there is hate speech in the
world on a percent. You know,
you don't want it on your platform, but
you've got to decide what is hate speech,
when is it really hate speech?
And when is it just ignorance.
And sometimes the best way to combat bad
speech is to let that speech play out
and let good speech overwhelm it with
logic and reason and a better argument.
That's, that's really what freedom of
speech is supposed to be all about.
That we work all this out.
As soon as you start censoring voices
and telling people that you're not going
to allow them to talk,
boy, you, you, you start,
you create this atmosphere where you
can start to choose what you're going to
allow through and when you're
not going to allow through,
and then you're gonna start censoring
things that are far more subtle.
You're going to start censoring
things that, you know,
they don't seem reasonable,
but you've decided that
it's already okay to sensor.
So you've censored this person nagging
a sense of the next worst thing, right?
And you're going to go down the line
until it's just people that disagree with
you.